elle est une pionnière de l'écologie
forestière professeur à l'université de
la colombie britannique susan cimade a
révolutionné notre compréhension de ces
immenses êtres vivants que sont les
arbres notre collègue de l'émission
découverte dominic forget l'a rencontré
[Musique]
dans les forêts pluviales de la colombie
britannique une femme écoute les arbres
la scientifique susan simard est une
vedette de l'écologie forestière
ces recherches ont révolutionné notre
façon de voir la nature
elle a montré que les arbres
communiquent entre eux
s'échangent des messages grâce à un
réseau souterrain de racines et de
champignons
le plus grand veille sur les plus petits
nous avons rencontré susan se meurt à
port cros dans le sud de l'île de
vancouver
[Musique]
quand vous êtes ces petites 9 passes et
déjà beaucoup de temps dans la forêt ça
vous a marqué
je passe mes étés dans un camp de
bûcherons c'était une opération familial
mon arrière grand père mon grand père et
maisons étaient tous bûcheron on les
suivait dans la forêt c'était captivant
on ne connaissait que ça la brousse on
appelait ça la brousse
commentait ce que l'industrie forestière
changé depuis l'époque de votre grand
père
ça a changé radicalement
à l'époque il travaillait à cheval
imaginez les arbres qu'ils abattaient
était immense il faisait 1 2 m de
diamètre
pour les couper avec les sites l'époque
ça prenait une ou deux journées
il n'avait été pas beaucoup d'arbres
pendant un été il prenait seulement les
arbres qui pouvait vendre
le plus souvent c'était des cèdres qui
servaient à fabriquer des poteaux de
téléphone mais qui travaux fonds propres
l'industrie forestière d'aujourd'hui est
complètement différente
elle rase tout ces pratiques ont été
développés avant qu'on prenne conscience
des changements climatiques ou qu'on
s'inquiète pour la biodiversité
susan simard a suivi les pas de ses
ancêtres au début de sa carrière elle a
travaillé pour l'industrie forestière
elle avait de constater que les choses
ne tournaient pas rond les arbres
replantés par l'industrie après une
coupe à blanc était chétif lorsqu'elle
est comparé au jeune pousse dans les
forêts naturelles
j'ai commencé à sortir les jeunes
pousses de terre et j'ai remarqué des
différences majeures au niveau des
racines sur les semis planté par
l'industrie les racines ne poussait
pratiquement pas même après unanime de
l'inter en revanche les jeunes pousses
des forêts naturelles avait des racines
qui s'éparpillent est partout il était
couverte de champignons
[Musique]
les champignons tons pâles susan cema ce
sont de longs filaments qui poussent
sous terre
ils forment de vastes réseaux
souterrains qu'on appelle le mycélium
sauf oui et puis si on creuse un peu on
va voir le mycélium
il y en a juste ici vous voyez les
filaments aux play offs et blanc assez
opaque c'est ça le mycélium
dans les forêts plus sèche on les voit
très bien c'est comme des toiles
d'araignées pour le grand architecte
dans les forêts pluviales c'est plus
difficile de les voir mais ils sont bien
là ce mycélium se connecte aux racines
des arbres ils s'entraident mutuellement
mais si le 13 avril le mycélium absorbe
des nutriments et de l'eau dans le sol
et les envois vers l'arbre en échange
l'arbre fabrique des sucres à partir de
la photosynthèse et en envoie au minium
à l'époque où elle travaillait pour
l'industrie forestière tout cela était
encore nouveau pour la jeune
scientifique
à louise tirant sur les jeunes pousses
je me suis demandé si ce réseau
souterrain de racines et de champignons
expliquer pourquoi les arbres plantés
par l'industrie était aussi chétif
plusieurs années de recherche plus tard
je suis pas mal certaines que la réponse
est oui
après votre courte carrière dans
l'industrie forestière on s'est retourné
à l'université qu'est ce que vous
vouliez
j'ai monté une expérience où j'ai planté
des pousses de bouleau blanc et de
sapins de douglas je les ai couverte de
cette plastique j'ai injecté du co2
marqué au carbone 14 dans l'air autour
des bouleaux blancs sous les sacs
plastiques autour des sapins j'ai
injecté du co2 marqué au carbone 13 par
photosynthèse les arbres ont fabriqué
des sucres qui contenait les traceurs
après un certain temps on a détecté du
carbone 13 dans les boulots et
inversement du carbone 14 dans les
sapins ça voulait dire que les arbres
communiqué ils échangeaient des sucres
par leurs racines et le mycélium
ensuite j'ai commencé à faire de l'ombre
sur les sapins pour ralentir leur
photosynthèse
les sapins était à l'ombre plus les
boules ou leur envoyer des sucres pour
compenser
j'ai fait cette expérience parce que
l'industrie forestière a toujours
considéré le boulot comme une espèce
nuisible elle coupe les boulots ou les
élimine avec des herbicides parce
qu'elle les perçoit comme des
compétiteurs pour les sapins qui ont
plus de valeur économique mes
expériences ont montré que les arbres ne
sont pas seulement des compétiteurs ils
peuvent aussi coopérer
[Musique]
vous avez montré que les forêts sont des
lieux de socialisation
ce sont des créatures sociale oui hausse
comment l'industrie a réagi avec des
couleurs il y eu énormément de
résistance je leur disais qu'il fallait
conserver les boulots dans les
plantations mais il y avait tout un
monde économique pâtit autour de leur
élimination
la chercheuse qui était devenu
professeur à l'université de la colombie
britannique n'a pas baissé les bras
elle a poussé plus loin ses recherches
sur les réseaux de communication entre
les arbres sonar brumaire c'est un arbre
mère quand est ce que vous savez lui il
est énorme
c'est un des plus grands arbres de la
forêt
susan semmar a découvert que les plus
grands et les plus vieux ce arbres de la
forêt protège les plus jeunes
elle les a baptisés arbres mer
on a fait plusieurs études qui ont
montré que les vieux sapins de douglas
peuvent reconnaître leurs descendants
ils ont plus de connexions avec les
jeunes pousses qui sont issus de leur
gréement il leur envoie plus d'énergie
c'est pour ça qu'on a surnommé ces vieux
arbres des arbres mer il veille sur les
petits
ils jouent leur rôle de protecteur
jusqu'à leurs derniers jours
c'est un long processus
ça se passe très lentement surtout dans
les forêts anciennes
au fur et à mesure que les arbres se
décompose ils transfèrent leur carbone
vers les arbres plus jeunes surtout à
leurs descendants
sow avait finalement obtenu la
reconnaissance de la communauté
scientifique vous savez maintenant un
projet de recherche importants sur les
arbres mais
c'est un réseau de 25 forêt qui s'étend
du nord de la colombie britannique
jusqu'à la frontière américaine elle
traverse différentes régions climatiques
de froid et humide à chaud et sec ce
sont essentiellement des sapins de
douglas
dans chaque forêt on étudie des
solutions de rechange aux coupes à blanc
la seule chose qu'on devrait conserver
certains arbres au lieu de faire des
coupes à blanc c'est exactement ça on a
constaté que lorsqu on conserve les
arbres mer la forêt se régénère beaucoup
plus vite après une coupe
quand on coupe un arbre mer le réseau se
désintègre les connexions
s'affaiblissent parce que ces immenses
arbres ont de longues racines hyper
connectés commencera avec nateur ce
cèdre ici est connecté aux autres autos
si on enlève tout le réseau va dépérir
en 2021 susan semmar a publié un livre
finding de moddeurs cris c'est
rapidement devenu un best-seller
[Musique]
j'ai écrit le livre pour rendre mes
découvertes accessible à tous j'ai
publié des centaines d'articles
scientifiques pendant ma carrière mais
personne ne les lit c'est trop pointu
pendant ce temps-là l'industrie continue
de faire des coupes à blanc
je voulais que les gens puissent
s'approprier ma science et prendre part
aux décisions sur l'avenir de nos forêts
[Musique]
pionnière de l'écologie aux états unis
hollywood veut faire un film sur vous
avez vous pensé que la foresterie fret
vous une vedette jamais de la vie
honnêtement les attentes n'étaient pas
très élevé
mais les forêts sont toute ma vie je les
aime passionnément indépendant d'elle
malgré les coups durs au cours de ma
carrière j'ai persévéré j'ai poursuivi
mes recherches parce que je voulais
défendre les forêts
et je ferai jusqu'à mon dernier souffle
[Musique]